[Applause]
hey what's up it's marco pilani here
with another million dollar win great
hey
hey y'all know what it is
we've arrived to the end of conference
championship weekend and the matchup for
super bowl 56 is set it's gonna be
matthew stafford in the los angeles rams
versus joe burrow and the cincinnati
bengals
what's up guys it's natalie obviously
very sad that we're not able to be on
the ground at this super bowl this year
but i think i have an idea of how i can
make this journey to my first bet just
as exciting as if we would have been in
la so on this journey of trying to lock
in my perfect first super bowl bet i say
we leave no stone unturned i wonder if i
can convince vr so let me do it
[Music]
so in this journey to locking in my
first ever super bowl bet i hope that
all of you guys can see just how much
actually can go into deciding how to
place a wager the world of sports
betting and gambling in general and
really how it's so much more than just
an amount of money you're willing to
risk on a game or a player or an outcome
but the entire culture that surrounds it
and all the variables and really all the
fun that can come from it
what better way to kick this off than
going back to the roots getting some
motherly advice and calling my mom for
our first lock who by the way knows
nothing about bedding
hey mom i like the super bowl's coming
up right
i need a lock mom
what made you decide the bengals
all right you guys we are about to face
time with greg i will say i'm sure he's
still a little bit shaken up a little
sad about the 49ers a lot yeah so
hopefully he has some good answers for
us and he's over that that niners last
but i guess we'll find out i know it's
been tough are you mentally over the
49ers lost no i'm not i'm upset natalie
i mean it hurt me i was at the game but
you know
i'm i'm slowly but surely getting over
it this matchup what are your thoughts
i can't rock with the rams man
they shouldn't even be in the playoffs
this was the 49ers super bowl to win i'm
not going with the pickles give me the
point you're most confident a lot
all right just talked to greg as
expected he's still a little bit
heartbroken about that 49ers loss but he
did tell us he's rocking with joe burrow
he likes the bengals against the spread
at plus four and a half he also liked
the over this game and interestingly
enough he said his favorite prep is the
national anthem he might have some intel
for us so we will stay tuned there
overall great insights from greg
when it comes to the national anthem
over under prop i decided to take it to
the lab today as i filled out my first
ever super bowl bet slip this year
singer is mickey guyton and she has an
over under set for 95 seconds way below
the average of 114 seconds since 1990
but keep in mind there are outliers
involved here like when alicia keys
brought the piano and belted out the
longest anthem of all time but i dialed
up all the x's and o's that are pointing
to the potential that this year's super
bowl anthem could be a lot to go under
but don't take it from me
this same singer sing the anthem back in
may 2021 to the tune of 86 seconds nine
seconds below what's projected for the
super bowl some are even dubbing her
quickie mickey could this be a lock to
go under
what color gatorade will be poured on
the winning coach we have an odds board
with all of the colors flavors so akib
who decides this you've been in a super
bowl who picks the gatorade color these
decisions are made all the way in
training camp
voice messaging system
hey it's natalie again it's my third
time calling just want to see if you
guys had any large shipments a blue
gatorade southern california area this
week
we decided all in all this really might
just be up to chance but we crunched the
numbers and found out that purple the
biggest value play at plus 1200 will
have its 10-year anniversary last year's
when the giants won in 2012. but we
needed to console the secondary source
we turned to the wheel of locks it also
chose a big value play of purple it
might be destiny purple might be due
what do you think
we paid fortune tellers to give us their
super bowl prediction i asked this one
about the coin flip the color of the
gatorade he said that he couldn't give
me any other props but that he could
tell me that the rams would win
then we decided to get a fortune teller
on the phone to see what they would
come to say right place i think what
defines me are my abilities to connect
with powerful forces this is definitely
a first because i can definitely sense
some conflict when i see a majestic ram
holding its ground
that is where i think the fortune and
prosperity lies
in route to lockheed my first ever super
bowl bet slip we've done everything we
talked to my mom for her super bowl pick
greg for his picks we researched the
anthem prop we researched the gatorade
prop we even hired fortune tellers to
look into the future it all comes down
to this
after much deliberation
the choice is clear we're going bingles
plus four and a half
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
it is monday the day after the super
bowl congratulations to the los angeles
rams
and congratulations to us for cashing my
first super bowl vet bengals plus four
and a half
i will say though not as much luck with
our props but our winner bengals plus
four and a half did cash and next time
i might just choose an outright winner
because my heart did get invested in the
bengals coming up with the win joe
burrell great story
but we still the cash that's all that
matters and this whole journey going
through fortune telling look through
cultivating luck it ended up just coming
to a point where i had to bet with my
heart and i was on the right end of it
this time
so great experience great super bowl and
most importantly great super bowl cash